es posible que el médico le recomiende
una cirugía laparoscópica para reparar
una hernia incisional o ventral una
hernia ventral puede verse como una
protuberancia anormal debajo de la piel
del abdomen
y la protuberancia puede ser de sus
intestinos que están ubicados dentro de
su abdomen
una membrana fina denominada peritoneo
cubre la mayor parte de los órganos
abdominales incluyendo sus intestinos
los músculos abdominales rodean el
peritoneo
y su piel cubre la pared abdominal estas
tres capas amortigua y protegen a los
órganos internos
si usted ha tenido una cirugía abdominal
en el pasado es posible que aparezca una
hernia ventral en la zona de la cicatriz
de la cirugía
aquí su intestino ejerce presión a
través de una zona debilitada en el
tejido entre los músculos abdominales y
crea un bulto debajo de la piel
el tejido peritoneal que rodea el
intestino herniado se denomina saco de
hernia si su hernia no se repara pueden
producirse complicaciones
por ejemplo la abertura de la hernia
puede crear un bucle con el intestino lo
que podría bloquear parcial o
completamente el paso del contenido en
este y se produciría una condición
denominada obstrucción intestinal
es posible que experimente síntomas
tales como dolor vómitos y constipación
la obstrucción intestinal puede causar
una estrangulación una condición en la
que se corta el flujo sanguíneo del
intestino
como resultado un segmento de su
intestino podría morir
para comenzar el procedimiento el
cirujano realizará una pequeña incisión
en el abdomen luego colocará un tubo
pequeño denominado puerto dentro de la
incisión
bombear a gas de dióxido de carbono a
través del puerto en el abdomen para
expandirlo
para poder visualizar los órganos
abdominales con mayor facilidad
a continuación el cirujano hará otra
incisión e insertar a otro puerto
pequeño
a través de este puerto el cirujano
insertará un laparoscopio que es una
pequeña cámara que proyecta imágenes en
un monitor para guiar el trabajo del
cirujano
mientras revisa la superficie interior
del abdomen
el cirujano realizará dos incisiones más
e insertar a dos puertos más
luego el cirujano insertará instrumentos
quirúrgicos angostos a través de estos
puertos para comenzar la reparación
se extraerá el tejido de cicatrices de
operaciones previas de ser necesario
luego el cirujano cortará el saco de la
hernia para permitir que el intestino
regrese a su lugar correspondiente en el
abdomen
el defecto de la hernia se cerrará con
suturas
luego el cirujano cubrirá esta zona con
un pedazo de malla
al final del procedimiento el cirujano
retirará los instrumentos las incisiones
se cierran con suturas o pegamento de
piel y se cubren con cinta de cierre de
la piel
si hay complicaciones con el
procedimiento laparoscópico el cirujano
optar a por un procedimiento abierto con
una incisión más grande